all right in the garfield house i mean
many many people are calling this the
year of andrew garfield not not just
because of your success for the
of this movie but the return of
spider-man as spider-man your fan
yourself what was it like to have all
three
i mean together i'm so happy that i get
to talk about it now because it's like
i've it's like i've been i've had so
many different hats on in in the sense
of like
like first and foremost i am a fan
so when
so when amy pascal and kevin feige and
and john watts
um asked to have a word with me and talk
to me about an idea and they and they
pitched it
it was like i be i was the fans in the
audience watching it on screen for the
first time with like the the three
the three spider-man across
universes are sharing a frame together
and like your hair your little head just
explodes so like i
like that's the main thing in me that
i'm that i feel about it yeah and then
the fact that i get to be one of those
people wearing the suit next to
my actual spider-man hero toby maguire
and
the the brilliant incredibly talented
heartfelt funny good sweet
perfect spider-man of tom holland and
then i get to be the middle brother and
i get to be like in awe of my older
brother and in full longing to protect
my younger brother and just like and
also there's something spiritual that
that kind of happened and happens and
that we were exploring in the film which
is like
you know archetypally the character is
so alone
the the isolation that that's a big
important part of the character in in
terms of the canon of spider-man for me
anyway and i think one of the reasons
why i think it's so appealing to so many
people around the world is that feeling
of
solitude that we can all
and loneliness
maybe is a better word that we can all
relate to
as we are figuring out our giftedness as
we are figuring out our ordinariness and
how that meets our extraordinariness and
going through adolescence and becoming
of a full person like
the the the loneliness that that
character feels archetypally that he
seems destined to feel all of his life
suddenly gets broken open
and these three guys
who maybe felt very lonely in the
universe before suddenly are aware
that they're never alone they never have
been alone and actually there is a
brotherhood out there and god knows how
many more spiderman peter parkers there
are out there to share in that support
group with because that's what it felt i
decided to feel like a kind of like
strange peter parker spider-man support
group like a kind of you know like a
12-step program for spider-man and peter
parker's and and the beauty of that like
the beauty of
like
what the writers crafted and what we all
crafted together of
you know
trying to
trying to you know to to save
our younger brother from
you know the paths that we've tried i
found that deeply moving mentorship like
the theme of mentorship and
and how these two people across the
universe were the only ones that could
really
fully understand what this young man was
going through and that was always that
was really important to us as well that
it was really about tom and tom's
character tom's peter tom's journey
as them as the center that and we were
just there to kind of support and have a
lot of fun and it was so much
fun i can't belie i still can't believe
it it happened and i'm just like
you know i snuck into a theater one like
on opening night
and just watched from like with my
baseball cap on my mask and just kind of
like
and uh in fact i was actually with toby
me and toby snuck into a theater
together
no one knew we were there
epic epic i love that so much
uh
and yeah it was just a really beautiful
thing to share together and to find a
brotherhood with toby as well and with
tom and and the fact that we have shared
that we that we do share a very unique
experience how that all came about could
you would you do it again do you would
you put the suit on if given the
opportunity
i mean
i
you know never say never i mean it's
such it's it's a character that's always
gonna be so meaningful to me and so
beautiful to me and
again it comes back to service you know
i think
if there's a way because that's what's
that's what that character is all about
he's all about
serving the greater good and serving
his fellow
fellow people his fellow you know
serving humanity and all life you know
so if there's a way
for me to
continue to add to the legacy of that
character in a way that feels
like it's
of service to an audience of service to
the themes of you know the themes that
stan lee
kind of uh you know injected that
character with i'm open of course i'm
very very open do you know how many
jonathan larsons there are
one why should we place a trail
there's not enough time
i went to three friends funerals last
year
and nobody is doing enough
i'm not doing enough
try writing about what you know now palm
springs is always the official start of
ward season and you're a part of this
thing what is it
what is it like what is it i know this
this film is connected to you deeply for
many reasons but what what's it like for
everybody to be recognizing tiktik boom
oh my goodness where do i begin with
that question i remember the first time
we screened the film for a sag audience
for
you know sag membership um viewers
and i we were in los angeles it was i
think the day after our premiere
and um and i remember being in the in
the kind of like the hallway before we
were going to go and do our q a
afterwards i was with elaine and the
rest of the company i turned to lynn i
said i have a feeling
that this is going to be a special night
because everyone in that audience
this is their story everyone who's ever
held a sag card everyone who's ever been
as
as audacious to follow their own dream
whether it was artistic or otherwise
this is their story this is our story
just so happens to be through this
symbolic lens of jonathan larson who
happened to be the quintessential
devoted artist who could not let go
of his own very particular unique thread
that pulled him into life
and that he knew he had to leave behind
all of his giftedness and i think we all
have a sense of that we all have an
opportunity to live in that way and i
think that's one of the reasons why it's
connecting with people in a way that
goes beyond you know a film you talked
about feeling like your mom was in every
frame of this movie and your connection
uh you know as you promoted the film
does being able to talk about this
character and the experience uh
allow these emotions to live on with you
as as time goes on i feel like
there's such a special that's the other
special side of this film is that your
connection with your mom and to the
material and all this does that carry on
with you now oh my gosh of course yeah
entirely you know to have the
opportunity to honor
to honor jonathan
in this way every morning to wake up and
just kind of devote myself at the altar
of jonathan larson
but while simultaneously i was able to
put
my mother's song
my mother's unfinished half-finished
song
right next to jonathan's unfinished
half-finished songs
that that personal connection i think
again it's it's what makes
all stories all are so universal just
just just the fact that
what jonathan has to
allow for what he has to understand and
be initiated to in the course of this
story is
this acceptance that life
has to include loss
it has to include
an awareness and a knowledge of the
finite nature of the amount of breaths
that we get to have here
the amount of
love that we get to share here the
amount of
tender infinite moments that we get to
live within
i i think as he understands as he as he
grows into a man as he grows into an
adult and starts to realize
oh my gosh i might lose my best friend
oh my gosh i might lose my own song oh
my gosh i'm gonna lose everyone in my
life
i think that is what invigorates him and
it's definitely something that i can
attest to with my own with the recent
loss of my
you know arguably the most important
person in my life with my mother
that actually that loss
if if faced if if met if accepted
as a bigger force then i can
contest
the thing that's chasing all of us
that that actually is what makes life
as meaningful
as it can be and as it actually is if we
allow ourselves
the um the the privilege of our grief
the privilege to remember
that this
is temporary that our conversation right
here right now is temporary and that
there's no way of living a life of
meaning without that so for me that i
get to
that i got to share and explore that
with my fellow artists with lin-manuel
miranda with with alex ship with roman
de jesus and everyone else
that we all got to bring our own ghosts
we all got to bring our own griefs our
own longings our own dreams
and to live through that awareness that
we all leave here with an unfinished
song
and the fact simply that i got to sing
for my mother that i got to sing her
across the river that i got to keep
singing the song that i wish it could be
here herself to sing
but in lieu of that i will do my best to
sing it for her even now as i speak to
you i get to do that and i get to say
the name lynn garfield and i get to say
i love you mom and i and i and i hope
i hope that you're resting and at peace
and i hope you feel
proud and i hope you feel
and i know that she would even if i was
a murderer she would be showing up with
like chocolate chip cookies in jail
[Laughter]
she was that kind of mother and i'm just
so so grateful that i get to
say her name here to you and to whoever
who's listening and and to have her song
sung
on the kind of river of jonathan
larson's songs i find that quite quite
beautiful and quite moving and i'm just
incredibly grateful i'm humbled that i
get that i got to do it
i'm humbled that i that i get to do what
i what i love to do and then to be able
to talk to you about it and to receive a
an award for it it's a little bit
it's a little much like like it feels
like that your cup is overflowing and
then i quickly go to well there's this
over spill of of gratitude that i have
and i need to make sure i put it
where my mother would want me to put it
and i'd say you know what i'm saying i'm
like yes yeah we're like this this this
beauty this joy this gratitude like this
is
this is that abundant feeling of love
that abundant feeling of love that that
i was awoken to when my mom passed i was
like oh no that's all the all that grief
is all that unexpressed love and it's
abundant it's never ending it's it's
like it's a source that is never
exhausted like that my so so i
i'm feeling pretty overwhelmed by all of
this and and by the fact that i could
play my favorite character again in
spider-man and simultaneously
you know honor
my other favorite character jonathan
larson you know it's like it's pretty
beautiful stuff man i'm very very
grateful this film uh
it kind of has jonathan larson
persevering in the face of failure and
rejection and and many creatives as we
said earlier can relate to that uh talk
about a rejection that set you back in
your own career right i like to always
bring this up because it it makes us
reflect a little bit um something that
that that maybe set you back in your
career that really resonated during this
process oh my gosh yeah well i mean i
was thrown back to my early 20s you know
when i was just out of drama school
thinking
am i gonna survive you know like i would
have taken anything
the first job i ever did was a doritos
commercial in spain where i was playing
air guitar as it were the doritos as a
plectrum and i was like i've made it
like i'm just made
two thousand dollars for two days of
work that's it it's over
um and uh but no i had a big spell of um
unemployment which i think is a kind of
um
unnecessary lucky thing in a way i think
the the the
i think it kind of
it was my jonathan larson
superbia moment i had a year and a half
of waiting you know waiting tables and
you know working at starbucks and i was
a cricket coach i was i was just doing
any like telemarketing the whole thing
there was i remember i want i was so
desperate i auditioned for prince
caspian in um the chronicles of narnia
and i thought if this this could be it
this could be it and that handsome
brilliant
actor ben barnes ended up getting the
role and and i was so i was i think it
was down to me and him and i and i
remember like i was i was obsessed i was
obsessed and i was like why not why not
me why not me and ben barnes is a very
handsome talented man
in retrospect i'm not unhappy with the
decision i think he did a beautiful job